this is the document at the heart of it
it dropped about an hour ago and it is
these almost 60 page report into Dominic
Rob's Behavior it's taken five months to
get this far two complaints upheld the
rest dismissed uh there's a lot that
Dominic Robb will have found very
painful to read there's a lot that
suggests that he doesn't accept the
accusations of bullying and it's quite
explicit that although there are
findings that he behaved improperly he
doesn't believe he did so even now
that's clear uh from the document from
the letters that have been exchanged and
from the telegraph article that has just
come out uh but ultimately the bottom
line is that Dominic Robb is now out as
depth prime minister and as Justice
secretary because of the conclusions of
this report now I'm going to take you
I'm going to whiz you through as quickly
as possible some of the key bits that
we've managed to find uh in the last um
uh half an hour or so so we'll just
flash through various bits uh and it was
uh and this document really uh talks
about
um uh goes through inordinate detail
Adam Tully talked to Rob uh in which
Dominic Robb admitted that he was in his
own word inquisitorial direct impatient
and fastidious so Dominic Robertson
admitting some bits of behavior that he
thinks are absolutely uh a fine clearly
what he wants to do is make the case
that different interpretations of
behavior are what's going on here
um and that uh but as you get into the
report you can see here
uh that uh views differed uh and the it
was the precise nature of the way that
Dominic Rob liked to conduct uh uh uh
his work they'd like to conduct business
with his officials that caused in the
words of Adam Tully uh to distress uh
perhaps even harms the health of the
people that worked around him uh Dominic
Robert said it was my exacting standards
uh uh Adam Tolley doesn't come down on
his side in a number of uh respects but
this paragraph here gives you a sense of
the kinds of uh things that we're
dealing with so he thinks Dominic Robb
thinks that things are frustrating as
he's working inside uh the ministry of
Justice
um but here are the sort of Demands that
he's making he prefers to receive papers
in a set format so that he can quickly
assimilate the information in question
if this work is not provided to his
satisfaction he will in general say so
if in the course of meeting an attendee
does not in the PM Deputy Prime
Minister's view answer a question in the
manner which he regards as direct and
straightforward the Deputy Prime
Minister will likely interrupt one of
the key questions in relation to some of
the complaints uh is the is whether or
not the debt prime minister's style of
Conduct in a meeting and in particular
when frustrated goes beyond what would
normally be regarded as acceptable and
that's where we end up with a division
Dominic Robb says it was acceptable Adam
Tully says it wasn't acceptable
ultimately he's left his job but this is
a conversation Sam that's not going to
finish today uh it's got a long way to
go as different people have different
views of what happens in the workplace
and different approaches to it um he
says
as part of that
as we go through this report you come
across extraordinary paragraphs take
this one it's about the use of physical
gestures I heard a good deal of evidence
about the depth prime minister's use of
physical gestures in communication at
the most extreme and uh and which would
have been unacceptable this was put as
extending his hand directly out towards
another person's face with a view to
making them stop talking another example
of such is an allegation of loud banging
of a table to make a point at the upper
at the end of the spectrum he would be
which would be regarded as acceptable he
used defensive gestures to suggest that
a person should hold off from speaking
further so so this is an unacceptable an
unacceptable example of Dominic Ross
behavior in Adam toler's view is
extending his harm his uh his hand
directly out towards another person's
face with a view to making them stop
talking so everybody at home will have a
view whether they think that is
acceptable or unacceptable Adam Tully
says in the workplace that is
unacceptable uh Dominic Robb it would
appear disagrees
um but let's look at some of the things
uh that happened when Dominic Robert's
foreign secretary uh that uh talked
about later uh in the report
and there was an incident uh when he was
in the in the foreign foreign office and
uh he had formed an adverse view in the
way about the way that his officials
were conducting their work about a
particular project and doesn't say what
the project is uh but there was uh
something uh the Deputy Prime Minister
the front secretary was uh was unhappy
with
um as part of the process towards and
the implementation of a management
Choice uh he uh acted in a way which was
intimidating in the sense of
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
uh it goes on uh in the context of a
workplace meeting his conduct also
involved an abuse or a misuse of power
in the way to humiliate and undermine in
particular he went beyond what was
reasonably necessary in order to give
effect to his decision and introduce a
punitive element his contact was bound
to be experienced as undermining or
humiliating by the affected individual
and so it was experience so that's the
sort of nub of the of the kind of
allegation that you get in parts of this
report basically he was humiliating
staff undermining their confidence
um he would say he was pursuing exacting
standards and he was trying to uphold an
efficient workplace to get stuff done
but Adam Tolley say it did undermine and
humiliate uh civil servants who were
working uh with him and said he should
have been aware of this dominant Rob
disagrees that this was bullying uh but
he should have done uh according to uh
that report
uh if we go on uh you can see that in
one case it had a significant adverse
effect on a particular individual in one
complaint uh who took it uh seriously
the Deputy Prime Minister's conduct was
a form of intimidating behavior in the
sense of conveying a threat of
unspecified discipline so that the
allegation there is if you don't do the
stuff in the way that I like it you'll
face some kind of disciplinary sanction
um and uh the basically what you've got
there uh is Adam Tolley saying that he
should have realized uh that in like the
threat came through the basically it's
seen Dominic Rob going yeah you do know
you'll be in breach of the civil service
code if you if you continue to act like
that uh basically Adam's Tully saying
that kind of way of acting was
unacceptable uh let's look um at uh the
next uh bit sometimes the Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Robert take a strong
view that officials should have been
prepared should be prepared in advance
to answer his questions at a meeting and
in the event that he cannot do so offers
largely unconstructed criticism about
the banner so you don't come to my
meetings and and you're going to get
something of a roasting uh you know
Dominic Rob would say necessary to in
order to ensure that civil servants do
come prepared to a meeting it's quite
perfectly fair to get cross if the
people who work for you aren't ready
with the answer to the questions you
think uh and uh one of the things that
the Deputy Prime Minister used to do it
would seem in the absence uh would be to
complain about the ABS of what he would
call basic information or we go on about
the basics you haven't got Basics the
public airing of a comment of this kind
where others are present are not or may
not be well placed to judge whether the
criticism is well founded it's likely to
be experienced as an unfairly personal
criticism by the individual uh to whom
the comment is directed and was so
experienced by some individuals this is
again where this whole issue goes back
away from a subject of Law and actually
comes back in terms of politics is
somebody is the boss of an organization
standing there or sitting there okay
look you haven't just haven't done any
homework you haven't done the basics you
haven't got the got the information that
I want is that bullying is that
harassment is that not you know this is
something that ultimately has resulted
in Dominic Rob losing his job but
everybody at home will have their own
view about what they think constitutes
bullying what's acceptable in the
workplace
um and what uh was going on uh here we
go uh this is this is from the
conclusions Adam Tully says I overall
conclude that Dominic Rod's conduct
During the period that he was Secretary
of State for justice was on some
occasions abrasive do we think that's
acceptable or unacceptable everyone have
a view on that and since his personal
style which is intimidating or insulting
to individuals but not intended to do so
his conduct however was not abusive in
the sense of behavior which was intended
and specifically targeted so there is
some uh there is some limit to the
Judgment adverse judgment that Adam
Tully is willing to make he says he
isn't abusive he has been able to
regulate this level of abrasiveness
since the announcement of the
investigation so he's improved his his
behavior in the last five months but
Dominic Raab should have altered his
approach earlier particularly after two
of my senior civil servants in Whitehall
took him aside and said look you've got
to treat people uh better does he regret
what he did well here it says he has not
offered any apology given that he does
not accept anything uh was wrong uh and
so I think there you get the difference
between his View and the lawyers and you
can see how really this uh breaks down
and it's going to end up being a
something of a talking point for some uh
time to come then towards the end of the
conclusions you've got more uh sense
that Dominic Raab acted in a manner
which was intimidating going further
than necessary in order to deliver
critical feedback making unconstructive
critical comments about the quality of
work done and wanted uh stuff about the
basics so there you get that overall
sense of what we're talking about